this newspaper is one of the few
critical voices left in Turkey's news
media it gets right to the point
declaring prime minister recep type
heroines government must go this vendor
has been fined twice so far for
disturbing the peace right now there is
no freedom of the press in Turkey and
this squares noisy all over there just
out to keep me from selling my
newspapers but I'm staying right here
google orders on taksim square in
central Istanbul the police maintain a
constant presence mass demonstrations
against the governing party and its
policies took place here in May and June
last year for the past decade Turkey's
economy has grown by leaps and bounds
averaging around seven percent annually
now the Conservatives have been
overtaken by a corruption scandal
there's an appetizer basically it comes
down to infighting between two factions
of the governing party of course that
has consequences for the economy because
in a sense that political risk has
increased it easy cool I want the
machine give us a visor to little mutt
german companies are keeping a close eye
on developments lung and user is a
German Turkish family business they're
monitoring the current situation closely
the 29 year old daughter of the
company's Turkish founder has recently
joined the company like her father she
spent most of her life in Germany now in
Turkey she lives with a pervasive
uncertainty it's been blessed I've been
here for seven or eight months before
that I was at University and the
students were also discussing the
situation but I expect a lot of people
will be anxious they don't know what's
going to happen with Turkish politics
everything's changing in Turkey you
don't know what will happen from day to
day I'm next episode next attack
passiert
among other things the company makes
gaskets for the automotive industry it
had plans to acquire three new presses
but all new investments are on hold for
the time being the flam company based in
the western german city of Aachen has a
branch office in the Jacka Scoy
industrial park west of istanbul it
produces parts for kitchen stoves and
washing machines for bosch demons
speaking in June last year just after
the mass demonstrations in the Turkish
capital the CEO said turkeys image had
already suffered but he's even more
worried about the present crisis Mamma
Mia pad journeys dork personally I'm
worried that they'll be changes in
Turkey's political structure we need a
stable and secure government in Turkey
for our economic success one that can
govern then growth and a successful
economy will follow I've worked this
[ __ ] up I give that woman the company
is also struggling to cope with the
weakness of the Turkish lira it buys
some of the parts it needs for
production from Germany as the lira
loses value the parts get more expensive
are you people on the streets also seem
on edge Park is you run everyone's angry
and I'm at to the Turks have lost their
upbeat mood haven't you noticed a good
amuses nowadays Taksim Square seems
peaceful enough but the corruption
scandal is far from over and local
elections are coming up in March